hi drew barrymore hello eddie murphy
i'm so happy to see you yeah happy to
see you too
i mean in 1982 just a little little baby
and there we were maybe just a little
baby
you and i you're just a baby
i'm kind of young too i think i'm like
19 or 20 then yeah
i remember tim kazarinsky you you kind
of like you guys were
buddies that we became buddies with him
i did i gravitated towards him he was so
nice to me
you guys are cute do you remember doing
the e
uh t sketch you were mr t
looking for his boy e and um
i don't know if you remember this but
steven spielberg was there
um he was very protective of me at that
time i was so lucky
you know what's so strange about uh the
whole snl experience
so long ago and uh so there'll be
sometimes it'll be like a sketch on
and i won't even remember the sketch
i'll be watching it going what is what
is the sketch and
how what happens next it's like so much
it's so long ago and so many sketches
in between that and so much stuff a lot
of times i don't remember it
i don't remember that mr t sketch i just
remember everything from that
show very vividly but i too have like
you know surrealistic uh yeah
i can imagine you're a little baby when
you started i was reading about
how that you lean into being a spiritual
person
and um being centered and that you
said maybe you avoided some of the
pitfalls that were so
easy at your disposal if you will
because of spirituality is that is that
true
yeah i'm very grounded spiritually and
not so much
you know any religion just a connection
you know with uh
with god you know being a young person
in this business and
it's a lot it's like you got to navigate
through a minefield you know
so many ways you could just you know
destroy yourself
a lot of the people that that i've seen
it destroyed themselves a lot of my
contemporaries a bunch of my
contemporaries
with people like michael and prince and
whitney and people that came on the
scene around the same age that i
am you know they kind of you know it was
this
self-destructive thing that they had you
know
that's my biggest blessing that i got
started really early i knew what i
wanted to do really really young
and that i love myself i never hated
myself i never beat up on myself
i never was i always
i've always been my biggest fan
i love that you deserve to be um
because we're all there with you what
would you
say to someone who like does struggle
with like call it self-love i'm asking
for
myself because i love and respect myself
but i
fall off the wagon with total
self-flagellation and like
you know being too hard and not meeting
my own expectations do you have any
advice for me
it's an inward search in uh
and it's personal and it's just between
you and you
and the outside stuff you have to learn
to not
like i don't i don't even let i don't
let anything
that's not constructive i don't let
anything negative in
you have to train yourself to turn away
from it when you
when negative stuff comes in stuff
that's not constructive
you have to turn from it you're here
and then you're blessed you're here and
you're blessed
you already won so the negative energy
there's no time for that you won already
i know what you do every morning you
should do a you should do a victory
dance you should wake up every morning
do the truth very much victory day just
i won
[Laughter]
you won mama i feel like the world's
biggest winner right now
to hear such salient advice from
someone i have respected so much my
whole life and
in 1982 when you were when we did
saturday night live together
then you know you had done 48 hours
trading places
um uh beverly hills cop um by the way
you're delirious right in the middle of
that the red leather suit is right in
the middle of that
and what exact point was raw
to that right after coming to america oh
yeah so that's 87.
i could tell because i have a perm my
hair is that hair
you had such a succession of these epic
films you know you're so
young do you ever come down from those
periods of time where you have hit after
hit after hit and you're working working
working
i'll tell you what happened i'll tell
you what happened to me uh
i had it all the way together for years
and years and years and then what
happened with movies is uh
they started me offering you so much
money to do stuff
that uh i wound up doing all you know
what that's like you just don't be like
hey you want to give me
you want to give me that much money to
do that okay so
a bunch of movies like that and it's
forever like way after the way after the
money is spent
that movie is like still playing on a
movie channel
so it's like so i had i got to where i
stopped having fun making movies so i
had to take i had to take a time like
about in 2011 i think it was
uh i stopped for like eight years i just
stopped making movies
and that's where i had really really
quiet time and got
re-centered to where you know if i'm
going to be doing something i want to be
doing it because i want to do it
and all that and it got my i got it all
back together that way
that is the perfect answer to that
question and the reason i asked is
because
you know since that 1982 time and i had
even been working before that and so had
you but
we're still here we're still going it's
30 40 years later
40 years ago i said well i say you
should do the victory dance
how about this we're in the business
drew where people come and go
people come and go every five years it's
a brand new bunch of new faces and
it's a brand new and anybody that's in
this business for
as long as you've been in this business
as long as i've been in this business
i think you know that means that we're
not stinky
it's been firmly established that we are
not stinky